i saw you took a trip to the tesla
factory what were your thoughts after
meeting elon musk did you get to speak
too much uh i wouldn't say much we we
spoke probably for 20 minutes in total
uh not purely privately because there's
other people around but
you know i just that just barely gets
you to know the surface of someone like
musk because he's an amazing person and
god only knows what's
what's up with him all things considered
we saw his new truck he was taking
people out for a ride i i didn't
i didn't go out for a ride
uh the truck's an amazing piece of
engineering the factory is massive um
you know what do you say about someone
who built a functional electric car then
shot it into space on a rocket
he's a singular person but i thought it
went very well it was a very interesting
evening
so i was pleased to be there and
you know we sort of walked around each
other a bit and
it was just fine you guys interact a
fair bit on twitter
we seem to yeah yeah what do you think
that is why are you converging
i don't know i don't know exactly
we're both well known and i suppose to
some degree that
that increases the probability of that
kind of convergence
but
maybe he's aiming up
me too
he seems to be he's aiming up literally
he's ending up very literally yeah
definitely didn't he put a wasn't there
a space man a model of a spaceman in the
driver's seat of the car
that he put out into schools that's
certainly possible he's got a theatrical
uh twist there's no doubt about that and
a great sense of humor because that's
really funny to shoot your own car out
into space on a rocket that's
a pretty damn good joke
what is it
what is it that's
or why is it that someone like elon has
got himself to the stage where he can
say things that almost every other see
he's the richest man i don't think he's
got himself to that stage i think he's
always done that and so now he he still
knows how to do it i mean you know
people think
i'll say what i have to say when i get
to the point where i'm protected and
secure it's like first of all
being protected and secure does not give
you the courage to say what you have to
say that's that's a completely
that theory couldn't be more backwards
you think you're going to get braver and
braver as you get more and more
protected you think that's how the world
works i mean i've watched university
professors
think that at some point they're going
to say what they think as they develop
their career but by the time they're
protected and secure they've spent so
much time not saying what they think
that they aren't even who they were and
they don't know what they think
so
no he says what he says because he's
always done that
and
people who are like him are like that
and so
steve jobs i presume was exactly the
same way i mean i know people who knew
him he always said what he thought and
and he was pretty damn cut and dried
about it which is why the apple products
are such miracles of of technological
mastery he had an unbelievably canny
design eye and was very
uh
he cut whole projects
without a second thought in some sense
when they were working he did that when
he came back to apple the second time
refined the entire product line got rid
of a ton of different things instead of
focusing on this yeah
right right so that was proof i mean
maybe it was fluke the first time which
it wasn't but coming back and doing it
again the second time showed pretty
clearly it wasn't same with same with
elon right he's refined down what he
does to
a couple of very very tight parameters
he seems to have although his hit the
enterprise he's put together is
unbelievably
high functioning i mean to produce a an
automobile sub industry that's actually
competitive and to
bring down the cost of space exploration
by a factor of 10 and to invent reusable
rockets and to have developed this
boring technology it's
it's miraculous it's probably an alien
yeah probably probably there's only two
probably a reptilian american car
companies i think that haven't gone bust
ford and tesla and tesla came very close
a number of times
yeah it's an amazing accomplishment
so
go elon as far as i'm concerned yeah
he's a remarkable person
[Music]
you